il ne se voit pas vivre sans elle jean
françois est éleveur de vaches laitières
et depuis quelques années ils croulent
sous les dettes
la descente aux enfers commence en 2014
quand un fournisseur lui propose un
aliment censé être bon pour ses bêtes
c'est un aliment qui était soi disant
révolutionnaire qui allait transformer
le dans la dans la pensée vaches pour qu
elle rumine mieux pour que ça soit il
mieux assimiler et finalement c'est un
aliment qui était beaucoup trop riches
en sûrs et et ça l'a fait à voir pékin 9
h les difficultés s'enchaînent aléas
climatiques
un prêt accordé puis retiré la
trésorerie baisse les vaches aux malades
et rendent de moins en moins de lait
aujourd'hui jean-françois ne s'en sort
plus son exploitation a été placée en
liquidation judiciaire le mois dernier
aujourd'hui c'est catastrophique
moi ça fait deux ans que je prélève rien
du tout sur la ferme pour vivre mon
associé il a été quatre mois afin de
payer donc il a quand même trois ans on
n'a pas le choix puis on a plein de
choses à payer la date butoir est fixée
au 5 juillet prochain d'ici là son
repreneur ses 130 vaches pourrait finir
à l'abattoir
le mandataire m'a dit qu'il vient
chercher les vaches qui les emmènerait
au cadran qu'elles seront vendus aux
enchères à
un groupe qu'il fallait le premier qui
va être intéressé mais ça sera que pour
faire du steak haché mais il va y avoir
un problème c'est que tu vois déjà qui
les emmène pas ce que je vais pas me
laisser faire et ça risque de finir très
mal parce que je suis déterminé à aller
jusqu'au bout pour pas que mes vaches où
il est battu pour espérer s'en sortir
jean-françois à créer une cagnotte en
ligne les fonds récoltés permettront
d'abord de soigner les vaches et
améliorer la qualité du lait l'éleveur
rêve ainsi de pouvoir sauver sa ferme là
où il s'est investi toute sa vie